like you know and what she did I went to
I forgot to say this what are you
attacking I want to taste it then that
you [ __ ] up on oh I was so Rachel what
this is Carla no yeah I'm gonna tell you
what are their sweaty this is the first
time no you know what it is I'm gonna
tell you when I tell you what it is you
know what it is it's probably
retaliation for you calling me a cow for
three no no it's not that is before cow
oh the poor beef is pretty beef so in
December I go to yes I go to Hawaii to
do another magnum p.i this time around
[Music]
I'll go I won't be in the way you know
you do your thing [ __ ] rude is
because when you were going through your
institution yes and then after that you
had told me I don't want to be alone I
need actual physical support I want that
and don't say that I tried to like
hitchhike no no no you weren't here - no
I was that I needed you there I was
there I'd much rather stay it came out
wrong medication everyone communication
came out wrong I'm sorry okay I needed
her there for support I really did and I
like when she's there but what's the
joke story it's not a joke story this is
what she did so I defend you whatever it
is I don't know what it is yes so who's
a mistake for sure I know I can I say oh
you do - it yes so um so when I'm on
that show they pick me up at 5:00 5:30
in the morning and I don't come home and
until 8:00 9:00 at night and literally
I'm in every scene not only am I never
seen I have every other line in 12 hour
day and it's so much so and also I can't
really eat when I'm shooting because I
get like I'm just concentrating so at
nights I just I would get three hours of
sleep before I was asleep so one night I
was so tired I had such a big day the
next day and I like I just gotta get to
leap and I get to bed around 9:00 to in
the morning I hear this hello this is
were on the phone at the front desk
hello yes there's a green blinking light
in the room right that's so I remember
now let me picture I had to get up in
three hours right I just got into bed
right let it pass so you know I don't
know what it is but there's a green
blinking light we need to bring somebody
in there immediately
what so next thing I know I have [ __ ]
Hawaiian man there's a Hawaiian man in
the room now I'm up I'm in the outside
smoking I was so angry and I I just said
to her why but then she goes I don't
know why but why did you do it wasn't a
green blinking light it was a red
blinking light thing I might have it was
a green blinking light I had I have it
was a green blinking light by the way
car was no red yeah that's a lot each
night by the way that he would come home
really tired I would shut the lights I
would light a candle
I would like make sure that he was fed
like I did everything but once in a
while I do have like in the middle of
the night not it's actually more
frequent now than ever I have like these
weird panic attacks and it's always some
I don't know where it stems from but
I'll wake up and I'll find something in
the room that I'm panicking over it just
turns out that this was one of those
nights I woke up in a sweat and I
fixated on this blinking light and I
have this like irrational fear of carbon
monoxide like the first couple of the
first week that I that I slept here I
woke up I stayed up every night and it
kept asking my sister because she spent
a few days here with me I said do you
think they were inhaling carbon monoxide
I was I don't know why this irrational
fear for it but I think that that's how
I'm gonna die or something so I woke up
in the middle of the night panicked and
I saw I probably saw it blinking red so
I pick up the phone very quietly I swear
to you and I was
returned
I didn't ask someone to come I was like
so there's a light blinking in our room
and I was like I don't think it's
anything serious but can you just
confirm that it's supposed to be
blinking and they're like no we have to
get up there for security purposes I
said no you don't have to because my
husband's sleeping they're like no ma'am
I'm sorry because we're sending someone
up right now I was like no just being
really quiet though dude
but it's dude the guy didn't wake him up
it was my tiny little mouse voice that
will come up yes this is what I hear
what are you here hello green blinking
light come up here that's what I hear no
that's probably not what happened I was
so conscious but that I know that's
probably not what happened but that's
what I interpreted it yes you perceived
it that way yeah and so I call my god I
am never my dude this hotel every time
we've stayed there has always had some
weird like alarm issue and they wouldn't
if firefighters come in there the next
day the alarm went off randomly in the
middle of the night again yeah so I'm
not crazy but I'm also crazy so please
forgive me yeah a big baby don't ever do
that again I know okay that's why you
like uninvited me to the next ye trip
but you're coming back now yes you are
if there's a light someone needs to yeah
what if I died from carbon ah you know
what better safe than sorry that's what
I live by yeah but that happened there
but I really I don't care what you guys
say about magnum p.i I really enjoy it
who's saying anything you're on a list
for it